we're actually joined Now by swella
Brotherman who of course is one of the
people who made the cut for the first
round of voting or on the ballot we
worry that you weren't going to get
there
I've been incredibly honored and
grateful for all of the support that
I've been getting from colleagues and
it's just been a really enjoyable
campaign so far we're having great
discussions with so many different
colleagues about lots of different
issues and it's actually very energizing
for the party you think it's energizing
for the party others would say that
actually the mud slinging and some of
the briefing that's been going on could
actually be quite damaging for the
conservative policy at a time when
you've already got to win back the
transcounter was Johnson's restoration
listen we're the most successful party
in the history of British politics we
know how to choose a winner and we know
how to win elections I think uh I think
we've got this one so you've got to get
to 30 MPS backing you today to progress
to the second round have you got the
numbers
we're confident that we'll be able to
get through this round I'm incredibly
grateful for the support from the
European research group and we support
grateful for support from people from
various intakes all over the country yes
we're very confident that we'll be going
through to the next round looking
forward to this contest you've got
polling that's been out of conservative
party members and I have to say it's a
pretty difficult reading for yourself
when people are asked effectively who
your first choice was to be a
conservative Pastor neutral prime
minister we've only got five percent
you're in sixth place out of eight I
mean that's got to be disappointing
there are so many polls coming out so
you know this so well and in fact
yesterday I was really encouraged to see
another poll which would come showing
that my policy platform was by far the
most popular amongst red wall voters
because of things I'm standing for I'm
the only authentic brexit here standing
in this race I'm the one who's the most
firm on leading the echr to fix a small
boats
and I'm taking a firm line on identity
politics that's a winning plan very
popular according to the poll you say
you're the only authentic brexit here
wish you sooner Penny Morden I mean
potentially even Liz trouser might have
something to say about that well I think
when you look at our records I'm the
only one who's proven under extreme
pressure that I have a vision for brexit
I opposed Theresa May of deal in 2018
and 2019 I'm the only candidate who
spoke up at the time and stood down and
voted against it consistently none of
the other candidates did that so in that
regard I'm someone who took a stance
when it really matters and are you
concerned that the brexit vote the vote
of the right of the party could be split
and other candidates that in the race
yourself of course chemical too and
actually if you look at some of these
polling figures that you got certainly
which does perhaps show that others have
got a better chance of winning at a
final runoff than you are you having any
conversations to try and coalesce around
one candidate of the right so we're all
running on our own platforms and we all
want to be the leader of this great
party uh we'll see how the results go
and we'll respond accordingly but you
know I'm here to win it I'm here to be
the leader of our party I'm pitching to
be the prime minister of this country
and and I encourage all of my colleagues
to get behind me but whoever wins this I
will be supporting them wholeheartedly
you're talking about responding to the
rounds just one just talk about
responding to the rounds as they go does
that mean that it does look as if
another candidate of the brexit within
the party or the right of the party
could be a better place to perhaps
because the final runoff you're not
ruling out standing out or down and
supporting them I'm running to win
Sophie and that's all I'm focused on
okay thank you very much